you know what on Feministing it was
overwhelmingly positive and supportive
when I when I got married and most of my
commenters were extremely happy and and
expressed as much I think it's it's one
of the difficulties in being kind of a
public or a semi public figure in any
sort of political movement that
everything that you do is analyzed
especially when you're online and
especially when you choose to write
about your personal life which which I
have done to to a large degree it kind
of goes with the territory but when when
I did get married and specifically after
I got married and the this the New York
Times Style section featured my wedding
in the in the vows column which is
really traditionally kind of seen as an
elitist Holliman it is but I was happy
to be in it you know I thought it was
good that they were covering covering a
feminist wedding and after that happened
and people seem so upset by it I kind of
had to just let it go you know you have
to have your personal life and and at
the end of the day I think what people
forget especially when you're online is
that you're a person too right and and
you're not this you know this ideal of
feminism that everything you do like
feminism just like falls in your wake
that's not how it happens like we're all
trying to negotiate a really difficult
and sexist world the best way that we
know how and we all make decisions that
are that are right for us and some of
our decisions might not be right for
everyone else and when we got married we
did the best that we could to kind of
incorporate our politics and our
feminism into the wedding it was
difficult for us because when we got
engaged it was right after a prop 8
happened in California so we had a lot
of conversation about you know should we
get married at all should we wait until
everyone can get married but to us it
felt like a really passive thing to do
to just not do something as a way of
expressing politics so for us you know
what we did was well in our ceremony
same-sex marriage was kind of a part of
what our efficient you know talked about
in in the ceremony we donated to a
organization that fights first same-sex
marriage rights and we indicated as much
like on little cards on the table and
and it was something that was just a
part of the ceremony and for us and you
know probably for a lot of my family
member as extended family members who
maybe are more conservative that was
kind of a radical thing for them to hear
and that seemed more active to us and
were activists to us than not doing
anything so that was the right decision
for us it certainly doesn't change
anything that's going on in the world
and it certainly doesn't make marriage a
fair institution or a not sexist
institution but it was the way we went
about it
you know I think that that almost all
traditional institutions are are sexist
and they're probably racist and
homophobic and they're all of these
things and but a lot of them like
marriage are too embedded into the
culture to give up like people are not
going to give up marriage but we can try
to make it more fair we can try to
change that institution and and make it
more equal and I do think that's
happening I do think that people are
what are aware of that and I think that
that's really the best we can do